Last time I introduced you to some of Rome's greatest buildings and I remind you
of two of them here,
the Pantheon on the lefthand side of the screen,
the temple to all the gods,
and then of course the Colosseum on the right hand side of the screen.
These are two of the greatest master works of Roman architecture and we will
gain momentum and work our way up to those in the course of the semester.
But it's not where we're going to begin.
We're not going to begin with these master works.
We're going to begin at the beginning and the beginning goes way,
way back,
in fact,
all the way to the Iron Age and deed to the eighth century BC.
And we know on precisely what day,
uh,
not only the history of Rome,
but the history of Roman architecture began.
And that was specifically on the 21st of April in 753 BC because it was on the
21st of April and 753 BC that according to legend Romulus founded the city of
Rome,
Romulus founded the city of Rome on one of Rome,
seven hills,
the Palatine Hill.
And I show you here a view of the Palatine Hill.
This is taken from Google Earth.
I urged you last time to make sure that you have Google earth downloaded on your
computer and to take advantage of using Google earth and the course of this
semester in order to really get to know the city of Rome and the,
the location of the various buildings that we'll be talking about within the
city fabric.
So I show you one of these views of the Palatine hill in Rome from Google Earth,
and you can see the relationship of that hill to the part of Rome in which it
finds itself.
You're going to be able to pick all of these buildings out by yourselves in the
very near future.
But let me just,
uh,
just do that for you here this morning.
Uh,
you can see of course,
the Colosseum in the upper right corner,
you can see the Roman forum lying in front of it.
Uh,
you can see the great that modern street that you see right behind the forum is
the via De 40,
and periodically,
uh,
commissioned by a Mussolini.
It'll do j.
Uh,
we can also see in this view,
the Capitoline hill with the Oval Piatsa designed by Michelangelo.
And down here,
uh,
the famous circus Maximus,
as you can see,
the great stadium,
the greatest stadium of Rome.
It wasn't the only stadium of Rome,
but it was the largest.
Uh,
and you can see it's hairpin shape,
uh,
right down here.
The hill in question right now is the Palatine Hill.
And this is the Palatine Hill.
All of this area here.
And as you look down on it,
as you gaze down on it,
you will see the remains of a colossal structure,
uh,
which is actually a late first a d palace,
that was designed under the direction of the emperor of Rome at that particular
time.
Uh,
a very colorful character that we'll talk about in some detail later in the term
by the name of demission.
This is dimensions palace on the Palatine Hill.
Uh,
but that,
that discussion of that palace lies in the future.
What I want to say today is miraculously the remains of Romulus is village on
the Palatine hill founded in the eighth century BC actually lies beneath the
remains of the palace of demission in Rome.
And it's to Romulus is huts on the Palatine hill that I want to turn to today.
Believe it or not,
remains of those huts from the Iron Age are still there.
Now.
They don't look like much.
Uh,
I'm showing you what remains of Romulus is huts right there.
And you're probably having a hard time figuring out exactly what we're looking
at.
Uh,
but what we're looking at the,
the architects that were working for the designers that we're working for
Romulus we're very clever indeed.
And they realize that the best way to create a foundation or pavement for their
huts was to use the natural rock of the Palatine Hill.
And that's exactly what they did.
What you're looking at here is the Tufa to you.
F a the natural Tufa rock of the Palatine Hill.
And what they did was they created a rectangular plan.
They gave it rounded corners and they cut the stone back about 20 inches down,
uh,
to create that rectangular shape.
They rounded the corners and then they put holes in the two for rock.
The holes were to support wooden poles that serve to,
to,
uh,
to support the superstructure of the hut,
and also to support the walls of the hut.
So the pavement,
uh,
of the,
the two for rock of the Palatine is the,
is the floor of the hut.
And then these holes,
uh,
support the wooden poles that supported in turn the superstructure.
I now show you a restored view on the left and you should all have your monument
lists and should be able to follow along with the major monument.
You won't see every image that we're,
that I'm going to be showing here,
but she'll show see a selection.
They are the ones that you'll need to learn and,
uh,
be able to talk about for the midterm of the two midterm exams in this course.
Uh,
but you'll see there,
uh,
this restored view of one of these Palatine,
Hud's as well as a view of the model,
uh,
that one can actually see in the archeological museum that's on the Palatine
Hill.
Uh,
today you can see as you look at this restored view on the left,
you can see that rectangular plan that we talked about.
Here you can see the rounded corners and you can see the wooden poles that were
placed into those holes,
uh,
to support,
the walls and the superstructure of the building.
You can see over here the same,
the wooden poles.
This gives you a better sense of what they looked like in actuality the wooden
poles.
And also the superstructure.
We also know what the walls were made out of.
They were made out of something.
And I,
you know,
I've put some of the keywords that I might be unfamiliar to you on the monument
list as well.
They were made out of wattle and Daub.
Well what is wattle and Dow wattle and Dab is twigs and uh,
rods that are covered and plastered with clay twigs and rod's covered and
plastic with clay.
Those that served as the walls of the structure.
And then the sloping roof as you see it here was fast.
Now it's very hard.
There are no huts that look like this in Rome still today that I can show you a,
to give you a better sense of what these would have looked like in antiquity,
but I'm sure you like,
I have seen huts like this on your travels around the world.
And one example I can show you and what would that we were all down there right
now.
This is a view of a small village in the Maya Riviera near Cancun,
uh,
where one sees if you take the bus or a car from Maya to Cheech an Eatsa,
which I hope some of you have had a chance to do.
If you haven't,
it's great,
great trip.
Uh,
and you can see all along the road huts that look very much like the huts of
Romulus,
these village made out of wood.
Uh,
and then with thatched roofs,
as you can see here.
So this is the best I can do in terms of conjuring up for you,
uh,
Romulus is village.
We also have information with regard to what these huts looked like in ancient
Roman times or not,
not nature them in the Iron Age.
As I mentioned before,
uh,
we have not only the pavement stone that's still preserved,
but we also have these urns,
we call them hut earns hot earnings cause their urns in the shape of huts.
Uh,
and these hut urns were used for cremation,
uh,
when people in the eighth century BC,
these date also to the Iron Age,
uh,
and the cremated remains of the individual was placed inside the door of the
hut.
And if you look at this hut earn a,
you'll see that it looks very similar to the huts of Romulus that we've already
been talking about it,
it is either sort of square or rectangular in shape.
It has rounded corners as you can see here and the roof of the hudder and is
sloping.
Uh,
so we do believe we use this along with the surviving pavement to restore a what
these uh,
hut earns,
what these huts of Romulus looked like in the eighth century BC.
Uh,
let me also note,
it's interesting just to see the status of men and women in any given
civilization at any given time.
There are essentially two kinds of Hud urns from the eighth century BC.
There are,
I mean there are two kinds of,
excuse me,
two kinds of urns in the eighth century BC.
One of them is hut urns and the other is helmet earns a,
and you can guess as well as as anyone is to who was buried in which the men
were buried in the helmet earns and the women's remains were placed in the hut,
earns a,
so men men's domain was considered the battlefield.
A women's domain was considered the house.
Uh,
but this how the houses are actually more,
uh,
more important,
in terms of giving us a sense again of what,
uh,
Romulus is village looked like in the eighth century.
And if you take one of those huts and you combine it with another set of huts,
uh,
you got,
you can,
you can get a sense of what the village,
uh,
of Romulus would have looked like in the eighth century BC.
This is a model that is on view in the archeological museum on the Palatine Hill
today,
and it gives you a very good sense of the village of Romulus in the eighth
century.
And of course it was from this village that the great city of Rome grew.
Uh,
and of course there's a quite significant difference between Rome as it is now
and Rome as it was in the eighth century BC.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna skip a couple of centuries and take us from the eighth century BC to
the sixth century BC and talk about what was the greatest,
our architectural project in the sixth century BC.
Now,
just a few words about what was going on in the sixth century BC.
Uh,
those who were ascendant in the sixth century BC were essentially the Etruscans.
The Etruscans,
uh,
lived in what is known as a area.
They were quite advanced civilization prior to the Roman period lived in
[inaudible],
which is,
uh,
which is essentially Tuscany today,
a trust in Tuscany,
Tuscany today.
So the area around Florence and so on and so forth is where many of these
individuals lived.
They became a quite powerful civilization,
uh,
and they were able to use that power to gain ascendancy also in Rome itself.
And there's a period in which there was a succession of a trust skin kings who
were,
who were leading,
uh,
Rome.
And these are trust.
Can Kings,
you know,
eventually kicked out of by the Romans.
Uh,
but at this time in the sixth century,
they were extremely important and it was under a trust skin,
uh,
supervision and patronage that a Ba,
a major temple,
uh,
began to be put up in Rome in the sixth century BC precisely in five oh nine.
It was dedicated in the year 509 BC.
As you can see,
uh,
from the monument list,
the temple in question was the temple of Jupiter optimists.
Maximas Capitol Lien is now that is a mouthful and I don't want you to have to
necessarily remember all of that.
Jupiter optimist Moxham is capital Lena.
So we will call him,
we will call this temple for all intents and purposes,
the temple of Jupiter.
Oh m see Jupiter Omc,
optimist,
maximus capitol Lenas,
the tablet cap,
the temple of Jupiter.
Omc,
uh,
was dedicated again in the year 509 BC.
Uh,
and it was dedicated to Jupiter,
uh,
but also to his female companions,
a Juno and Minerva.
I,
and when we think of those three are,
when those three are joined together,
Jupiter,
Juno in Minerva,
they are known as the capital line triad because their main temple was on the
capital line hill in Rome.
And we will see the Capitol on triad not only honored in this temple,
but in other temples.
I showed you one on Tuesday and palm pay,
for example,
uh,
the so called capitalism and Pompei that honored Jupiter,
Juno,
and Minerva.
You'll see that when a temple honor's the three of them,
it has implications for the architecture of that building,
for the design of that building.
We'll talk about that right now in a few minutes.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I want you to be aware of what the capital on triad is.
So it's all three of them honored together.
Although Jupiter is always considered a supreme when,
whenever those three get together.
So we have a temple here that we have to think of in large part as an a trust
skin temple put up during the time of the trust.
Can Kings,
uh,
dedicated in 509,
but one that is beginning to have,
uh,
the impact of Rome,
and will itself have very strong impact on Roman temple architecture.
And we're going to focus quite heavily today on Roman temple architecture.
And then of course,
return to it,
uh,
sporadically in the course of the semester as we move through and look at other
temples like the Pantheon and like others that were put up in the Roman
provinces.
The temple of Jupiter,
Omc was built on the capital line hill in Rome.
So one of the other major,
uh,
seven hills.
So while the hill,
the hill of the Palatine was basically the residential section of Rome at this
juncture,
the capital line hill became its religious center where it's main temple was
placed.
Uh,
the temple of Jupiter was located,
uh,
on the hill,
um,
was located on the hill and about the position of one of the palaces that's
there.
Now we mentioned last time in any of you who've been to Rome?
No,
this,
well,
uh,
that the,
Capitol Line Hill was redesigned in the renaissance by none other than
Michelangelo himself.
Uh,
it was Michelangelo who was responsible for creating the Oval Piatsa that is at
the center of the cap,
a capital line hill,
which was then recall renamed the competent Doleo of Rome.
And there are these three palaces designed also by Michelangelo,
the capitalized,
the conservatory and the senatorial palaces that served today as to museums on
you or I joined museum one on either side and a,
uh,
a,
um,
a governmental building in the back.
Uh,
and you can see that very well here.
So this is the capital on hill as it looks today,
as we designed by Michelangelo.
But in Roman times it was the location or from the sixth century BC on,
it was the location of the temple of Jupiter Omc,
the chief temple of Ancient Rome,
the most important temple of ancient Rome.
What did that temple look like?
A,
and again,
it's,
this is extremely important,
not only for it but for the rest of Roman temple architecture.
Over time we have,
believe it or not,
we have quite a bit of evidence.
Uh,
it's complicated by the fact that this temple burn down quite a number of times
throughout its history.
We know it was still standing by the way in the fourth century d when it was
described by a very famous writer.
Uh,
but so it had a very long history,
but it burned down several times.
Uh,
and uh,
it was rebuilt several times and each time it was rebuilt,
it obviously was rebuilt in a new style,
you know,
whatever was oak or wronged at that time.
So it changed considerably.
And nonetheless,
we do have quite a bit of information about it as far as we can tell when it was
put up in five oh nine BC,
it looked something like this.
What you're seeing here is a restored view,
a and a plan of the temple in 509 BC.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it's never too soon in a course on architecture to learn how to read a plan a
and to how to read a restored view or so called axonometric view.
And I have put on you probably haven't had a chance to look yet,
but I've put up on the website for this course,
both under announcements and also in the forum,
the online forum section.
A couple of sheets that you will speak I think will be very helpful to you that
have a terms and concepts.
Uh,
you know,
it has different kinds of different kinds of um,
vaulting and uh,
different kinds of masonry and also tells you the difference between an accident
metric view and a plan and so on and so forth.
I really urge you to print those out,
look through them.
Uh,
in the beginning of this semester.
We do have to spend a lot of time on what things are called,
but once we do that for a couple of weeks,
we'll be done with it and you'll know all the basic terms and we'll be able to
go on from there.
But I think you'll find those handouts extremely helpful.
So as we look at what we have here,
I think you can see by looking at the plan,
uh,
that what we are dealing with here is a rectangular structure.
Uh,
the rectangular structure has a deep porch and these circles are columns.
So with freestanding columns in that porch,
it has a single staircase at the front having a single staircase rather than one
that in circles,
the building gives the building a,
uh,
a focus.
There's a focus on the facade for this structure.
You can also see that the p,
the back wall is plane,
back wall is plane.
I am the seller.
C,
e l l a,
which is the central space of the inside of the temple is divided into three
parts.
So I try partite seller,
uh,
and why was there a tripartite seller?
You know the answer because there were three gods.
That was Jupiter,
Juno,
and Minerva.
The capitol I'm triad.
Each one had his own little Sela,
uh,
with Jupiter,
obviously in the center flanked by his two ladies,
uh,
one on either side.
So whenever you see a building with a triple seller,
you're going to know that's a,
that's a temple of the capital.
I'd try at,
we can see from the outside of the structure,
the restored view,
uh,
that it had a quite tall podium.
The podium was in fact 13 feet tall,
pretty significant,
13 feet foot tall podium right here.
And here you also see again the single staircase in the front.
Uh,
the facade orientation,
the deep porch,
the freestanding columns in that porch and the triple entrance way into the
three sellers of the structure.
So that's the basic plan.
Uh,
let me also mention the materials for the temple of Jupiter Omc in the sixth
century BC because technology is an important,
is important in any course on architecture.
Uh,
we know and think back to what we already know about the huts.
the bill,
the building material used here was a wood for the columns and the
superstructure just as we saw in the Palatine huts,
wood for the columns and the superstructure mud brick,
not waddling dow,
but mud brick for the podium and for the walls.
Uh,
and then the structure had,
uh,
quite a bit of decoration.
You don't see it here,
but quite a bit of decoration,
sculptural decoration,
uh,
in ancient times.
And this was made out of terracotta.
So would mud brick and terracotta where the materials used for this particular
building?
Oh,
I meant to show you,
sorry,
let me just go back for a second.
They don't,
the reason that the,
uh,
the other plan is on the screen.
The one at the left,
uh,
this is a plan of an interest in tomb,
the tomb of the,
uh,
shields and seats from cheer Vettery second half of the sixth century BC,
which is on your monument list.
I only bring it to your attention because it's interesting that the Etruscans
also divided the main space of that tomb into three spaces.
Uh,
three separate spaces up at the top,
tripartite,
uh,
and also gave it a single staircase,
which gave it a facade orientation.
I just mentioned that because we'll see that those,
that,
those,
that especially,
that focus on the facade is an a trust can element that is picked up by the
Romans.
Roman architecture is very much an architecture of the sides,
the front of buildings with a focus on the front of buildings.
And I wanted to make sure that you knew that not only in temple architecture but
also in to market texture under the Etruscans.
Uh,
that was a,
uh,
an approach that they already took and that was adopted from them by the Romans.
Uh,
another view also of the plan just so that you can see it again,
a straight up,
uh,
with the focus on the facade,
the single staircase,
the deep porch,
the freestanding columns in that porch,
and then the tripartite division and the flat a back wall.
And I think it's important at this juncture to make a distinction between the
most important,
uh,
trust skin temple,
namely the temple of Jupiter Omc.
And you see a model of that here and the most important Greek ancient Greek
temple,
the Parthenon in Athens,
the Parthenon in Athens dates.
As you probably know,
to the fifth century BC,
uh,
this to the sixth century BC.
So they are not exactly contemporary but roughly and a contemporary to one
another.
Uh,
and uh,
as you look at this,
I think you can see for yourselves,
although I will point point out,
uh,
the major distinctions between the two.
And this is going to be very,
very important for today,
for today's lecture,
but also in the future because what we're going to see is that the Romans,
when the Romans began to build their own religious architecture,
they looked back to what had been done by the Greeks and what had been done by
the Etruscans.
They picked and chose what they liked in each,
and they brought that together in an entirely new creation.
They mixed it up with their own culture,
their own religion brought it together,
an entirely new creation and created a,
something distinctive that we know of as the Roman temple.
So what are the,
what are the differences between the two?
We've already talked about the main,
uh,
main features of the Etruscan temple.
Uh,
but with what,
what are,
what,
what are the main features of the Greek temple of the Parthenon?
Uh,
I think you can see that while superficially they look alike,
they have columns,
it supported triangular pediment and so on and so forth.
Uh,
the major differences are,
and you can't see all of those here,
uh,
but the major differences are that instead of standing,
sitting on a high podium,
uh,
Greek temples sit on a much lower podium,
they have a staircase that encircles the entire building,
no facade orientation there,
no single staircase on the front,
the stairs in circle,
the entire building as you can kind of see here.
Uh,
and there is a single seller.
They never used the triple sellers we see in the capital on a temple.
Uh,
and uh,
and the major difference between the two perhaps is the fact that this building
is built out of stone,
out of marble.
The Greek building is built out of marble.
The Greeks using marble magnificently,
uh,
in the fifth and even fifth century.
And even before that.
So no,
no,
no ordinary old wood columns and mud brick for them.
They were using a marble.
So when we begin to see the Romans and we'll see that today using stone,
uh,
for their temple architecture,
they are doing that under the very strong influence of Greece.
And that's extremely important in any assessment of early Roman religious
architecture.
Another view,
and it's one that you have also on your monument list showing the capitalized
hill in Roman times,
showing you the situation of the temple of Jupiter Omc in relationship to the
other buildings that were up on top of the capital line tail,
mostly religious structures.
But I just wanted you to see it did not stand alone.
Not all of these were built in the sixth century BC already,
but over time and accretion of other buildings here you actually see the temple
and the somewhat later version because as I mentioned,
it burned down and it was rebuilt many,
many times.
Uh,
but you also can see here this is just useful in terms of Roman religious
practice.
The altar is located not inside the temple,
but outside the religious service actually took place outside.
The priest would officiate outside the temple.
And in fact,
very few were allowed to go inside to see,
uh,
the sacred called statutes that was pretty much left for the priest and the
priesthood.
Just again,
to underscore the importance of Google earth for anyone who is not here on
Tuesday,
I mentioned at that time,
uh,
that you can not only go and fly over Rome as it looks today by a Google earth,
but they have just recently in the last few months introduced in ancient Rome
version.
So you can go and,
and when you click the right button,
you click your mouse in such a way,
you can find that you,
uh,
that the whole city will be,
um,
completely recreated into the ancient city.
And I just want to do,
it's much more abstract.
Uh,
but nonetheless,
it gives you a sense of what many of these buildings look like in ancient Roman
times.
And this is a screenshot of the Capitoline hill as it appears in the Google
ancient Rome,
a version of,
uh,
of Rome.
You can't do this for the other cities at this juncture just for the city of
Rome.
But it's great fun to do and also very,
uh,
informative.
Now what is actually left of the temple of,
we know we've,
we've looked at the account,
but Dalia,
we see Michelangelo's buildings are up there.
Now what is actually left of the Temple of Jupiter Omc?
Well,
you're looking at it right here.
It's the podium of the temple,
still survives that 13 foot tall podium of the temple of Jupiter.
We think this is a quite early podium,
maybe not as early as the sixth century BC,
uh,
but a very early podium from the temple upon which the structure was built.
You can get a sense of the height of these things.
And again,
the characteristic of a trust in temple architecture.
And as we shall see if most Roman temple architecture is to have a high podium,
uh,
we can see that podium here and we can see what,
how it is made.
Technically you can see it as made up of a series of rectangular blocks that are
placed.
One next to one another and on top of one another.
This is technically called ashler masonry,
r Ashleigh masonry to build,
to build a wall with this,
these kinds of rectangular blocks,
uh,
po Po piled one on top of another.
It's to Firestone in this particular case,
once again,
which was natural at a to bestow natural to Rome,
to you f a,
uh,
and uh,
this,
uh,
Ashleigh masonry,
again,
a building technique that was particularly popular in the,
uh,
fifth and fourth and third centuries BC in Rome.
Now,
what,
what went up after the temple of Jupiter Omc in Rome quite a bit.
I mean,
this was a very inspiring project,
a very major project.
Obviously it's spawned a lot of other building projects in the city.
Very few of those survive.
I can't show you much else from this particular period.
And this is for a variety of reasons.
It has to do in part with those fires that I mentioned.
A lot of things burned,
uh,
and no longer survive.
It has to do with a,
something I mentioned also on Tuesday,
and that is that some of these buildings became quarries in later times,
uh,
with later patrons and architects using them as a source of stone,
that could be used in later structures.
Uh,
so many of them were dismantled,
uh,
to be used for other buildings.
Uh,
and also any city that is inhabited as Rome has been for two and a half
millennia is obviously going to lose a certain amount of its structures over
time.
They're going to be torn down,
they're going to be rebuilt,
they're going to be incorporated into other buildings at some of those that are
survive best are those that were actually incorporated into other buildings.
Uh,
and indeed,
that's what happened here.
The wall was incorporated into something else and built on top of,
and that's why it's still survives.
So we don't have all that much again,
uh,
besides this.
But even if we had whatever was standing,
uh,
in the fifth and fourth centuries or early fourth century BC would have been
destroyed in the year 386 because in the year 386 BC,
uh,
a group of tribes,
the gallic tribes,
the Gauls came down from the north.
Uh,
they destroyed everything in their path.
They did a lot of damage to the Etruscan settlements around Florence and so on.
They destroyed those.
They came into Rome and they set the city of Rome ablaze.
And when the smoke cleared,
and it did eventually clear,
the only building that was still standing was the temple of Jupiter optimists,
maximus capitol.
This,
that's how much destruction there was.
And so there's very little else that we can look at from this particular period.
What the sac of the balls did was also convinced the Romans that they had not
protected their city well enough,
right?
I mean,
they were completely exposed and the entire city was burned except for that one
temple.
So they realized that they better get smart and they better start to wall their
cities to begin to put a protective walls around the perimeter of those cities.
And we see a great,
um,
a great efflorescence of wall building.
Therefore,
after the sack of 386 BC,
and I want to turn to that wall,
uh,
construction.
Uh,
right now,
uh,
I want to begin with the most important wall that was put up in the fourth
century BC right after the galaxy.
Zach.
Uh,
and this was the wall around Rome itself.
A Rome was encircled with a stone circuit,
a stone circuit that,
that,
uh,
that went around the entire,
seven hills,
the famous seven hills of Rome,
and closing it in this stone circuit.
And fortunately,
some parts of that wall are still preserve today.
And I show you the most extensive section here.
This is called the Serbian wall walls.
You can see this on your monument list.
Serbian walls in Rome,
dates to 378 BC,
uh,
right after the sack,
not long after the sac,
378 BC.
Uh,
and,
uh,
some,
some extensive sections of that wall or preserve the most extensive is the
section near Rome's main train station.
The [inaudible].
You can see this Nazione modern building cause see the Staats Yonei mini in the
upper right corner.
And here is a view of this extensive section of the Serbian walls in Rome.
The Romans didn't want to take any chances.
They decided even though they're to FAU was pretty good.
Uh,
they decided they wanted to use the finest Tufa possible and the,
so they brought it in from the Etruscan city of Bay Bei.
They have AEE was a famous and important to trust can city,
uh,
that the Romans had just made their own.
So it was a perfect source for them of a,
of outstanding building materials.
And they brought in a,
an imported yellowish Tufa,
uh,
from the Etruscan town of Ey to use for this very significant,
very important,
a wall that was going to protect them from this time forth.
Uh,
and I,
you see that wall again here,
it is very weathered a,
even though it's still stands,
it's very weathered.
So the stones don't look as uh,
as,
as expertly a carved as they would have been in ancient Roman times.
And what you can,
it's hard to see here and I'll show you better in different wall shortly.
But what it's hard to see is the system of what are called headers and
stretchers Heteros and stretchers that they used for this wall.
Ah,
what a header is when,
when you,
you take,
you take the same size rectangular block,
but when you put the short side out facing out,
that's a header.
And when you put the long side of the rectangle facing out,
that's a stretcher.
So it's a,
it was a alternating headers and stretchers.
Again,
I'll show you that better in another wall momentarily,
but uh,
use of headers and stretches here.
And we can also see that the blocks are quite regular.
We are dealing with what we call a Ashleigh masonry.
Once again,
the same kind of construction is placement of these fairly regular blocks.
Uh,
one on one next to one another and one on top of one another.
Ashler masonry in Latin.
The term is opus Opu,
s quad dropped them Q,
u,
a d r a t u m opus quad,
drop them.
So this,
you can call this either Ashleigh masonry or opus quadro bottom squared work.
Uh,
the same sort of thing as we saw on the podium of Jupiter Omc being used for the
Serbian walls in Rome in 378 I showed you last time.
This section of the Serbian walls here,
you can get a much better sense of the coloration of that.
Yellow is Tufa,
uh,
from the,
and this is also very weathered,
so it's hard to see the headers in stretchers.
Uh,
but it's another section of wall.
And just in case any of you are going to Rome anytime soon that one can see on
the Aventine Hill,
which is a beautiful residential hill in Rome,
one of the,
one of those lovely places to wander in the entire city.
You will come across a another section.
You never know when little pieces of antiquity will crop up.
They come up in the most unusual places is one wanders the city,
which is one of the reasons it's such a fascinating place to visit.
Now the Romans realize what was going on at the same time as the Romans were
beginning to extensively colonize a while.
They had these imperialistic ambitions,
they want it to colonize the world.
Uh,
but they began with the places closest to them and they began to build extensive
colonies in Italy,
especially in an area very close to the city of Rome itself.
And they recognize as they began to build what I,
what I meant when I mentioned to you last time,
I like to call mini Rome's because these are little cities in the version of the
Capitol City itself.
As they begin to build,
began to build these,
these mini rooms,
they recognize that these mini Rome's also needed a security also needed to be
protected by walls that were comparable to the Serbian wall.
So we see this great efflorescence,
not only a colonization,
but also have wall building,
uh,
in the period following the sac and the period following the construction of
Rome's owned Serbian walls.
And I want to show you a couple of a few examples of that.
This is a map that was custom made for this course.
You can find it on the web portal.
Uh,
and I think you'll find it very useful because what I've done here obviously is
on,
I don't clutter it up with a lot of places.
We're not looking at,
I focused on the towns that we are actually going to be looking at buildings in.
So I think you'll find it extremely helpful.
Rome is here at the star.
You can actually click on the map and that will take you to a map of Rome
itself.
Uh,
but,
uh,
we see the star where Rome is and the towns that I'm going to take you to that
have walls are uh,
the city of Coza,
the town,
the village.
Really at that time of Coza,
uh,
the town of [inaudible] that you see over here and the town of Fillory,
Novi.
But I wanted to show you the map because you see how close,
how proximate they are to the city of Rome itself.
I'm going to show you these fairly rapidly.
Just to give you a sense,
again,
of the kind of wall construction that was going on in the colonies and the
Italian colonies at this time.
This is,
we'll look first at the city walls of the town of nor Ba.
Uh,
and you can see from the monument lists that dates to the second half of the
fourth century BC.
And as you look at these walls,
these are not done out of two [inaudible],
a local,
a local stone to Norbert,
more grayish and color,
as you can see here.
But you can tell me yourselves right off.
That's not opus Quadro Adam.
That's not ashler masonry.
The blocks are not rectangular,
and they're not that even.
In fact,
they're multi-sided blocks.
Some of them are polygonal blocks,
and we technically call this polygonal masonry,
and they've taken these multi-sided blocks,
piled them up in a very interesting way to create a very handsome wall.
I like this wall a lot myself.
Uh,
I very handsome wall,
uh,
two in circle,
the town of Norma.
So polygonal masonry in this particular instance,
and we see the same use of polygonal masonry at the town of Coza,
which is north of Norway.
As you'll remember from the custom map,
the town of Coza,
the walls date to 273 BC at Khoza and you see glimpses of them here.
And I think you can see once again a grayish stone,
a use for these walls.
And you can see that the uh,
the construction is once again a polygonal masonry,
the,
the PS to raise this dawns,
the greatest masterwork a Roman wall design in this early period is the wall
that you see here.
This is the wall at flairy.
Novi for Larry Nobi was founded as a colony and 241 BBC 241 BC.
And the walls were put up sometime between two 41 and 200 B BC.
And we see them here and you can see that the wall also had a quite spectacular,
at least for its date,
quite spectacular gate.
Now if we look at the walls for is actually,
first of all,
I want to point out that they have chosen to use due to different kinds of
materials here as is immediately apparent as you look at this color view.
Uh,
they chose to use a,
a gray pepper,
Reno stone,
I n.
O,
a great pepper Reno stone from the all been hills,
uh,
for the,
arch of the gateway and to use,
um,
a reddish brown Tufa bore the walls themselves,
Reddish Brown,
Tufa pepper,
Reno,
great pepper Reno stone from the Alban hills.
So they chose,
they were very careful about their selection of materials in part to emphasize
this distinction,
uh,
in texture and in color.
If you look at the wall,
you can see we're dealing here clearly with Ashleigh Mason,
we were the Oprahs quadro bottom.
And here you can see much more clearly than any of the other walls I've shown
you because there so well preserved the headers and the stretchers,
the alternating a square and rectangular blocks,
the scheme of headers and stretchers,
uh,
that is used for this wall.
The most important part of course is the arch,
the stone arch.
It's a masonry arch.
As you can see.
It's not the earliest arch and Roman architecture,
but it's one of the earliest,
uh,
it is,
has,
it has been amazingly done,
I think,
quite masterfully done.
Uh,
if you look at it,
you will see that what the designer has achieved is to take a series of
wedge-shaped blocks.
These are called [inaudible] blocks.
I put that word on the monument lists for you,
lose water blocks these wedge shaped blocks and has carved them in such a way
that each one fits very,
very effectively and very well into the overall scheme.
They're wedged in next to one another.
In fact,
as you gaze at it,
you kind of think,
Gee,
I wonder if any of those blocks are going to fall out,
you know,
fall out from where they are,
but they don't because they're wedged in a so closely next to one another.
And then they have finished the line of the arch,
uh,
very nicely so that it has a very attractive appearance.
Uh,
and,
and because it has done in a different stone,
it stands out extremely well from the rest of the wall.
This is really,
again,
a masterful treatment in my opinion of a wall at this particular time with the
wonderful addition of the arch.
Uh,
and I think we begin to see,
we talked last time about how important arch of making the arches and bolts and
especially the use of concrete,
although here we see a stone arch clearly has stone arch.
Uh,
but we are going to see that the capacity of the arch to be used for expressive
purposes in architecture,
uh,
is a,
is capitalized on by the Romans.
And I wanted you to be aware,
this is not only important as a wall of this period,
but important as a,
as in the way that it's precent of what's to come,
uh,
with regard to the way in which the Romans are going to start to deploy the arch
in extraordinarily creative and innovative ways in Roman architecture.
All begins here.
The arch of the gay,
the,
the wall and gate Valarie Novi stand at the beginning of this incredible
development enrollment architecture.
I want to say something very,
very quickly about,
uh,
the,
about town planning during this period because just as I mentioned,
Romans were colonizing,
uh,
towns in Italy,
and they were,
uh,
putting walls around them,
but they were also beginning to think about how they thought about,
uh,
about,
city construction in general or the making of urban spaces and places during
this particular period.
So I just want to show you fleetingly two examples.
Uh,
the town of Coza,
which we,
which we've already looked at the walls dating to the third century BC.
And it's worth noting that it was again after the sack of three 86,
that this explosion of town building a really began.
As we look at this,
the town plan of cozy,
you can see that it is encircled by the wall that we looked at just before.
Uh,
and you can also see it's roughly regular in shape.
You know,
roughly kind of a square.
As you can see here,
there are gates in the walls.
Uh,
and then there is a scheme of streets,
uh,
that is comparable to what I mentioned last time was typical for an ideal Roman
city plan.
And that is,
uh,
the two main streets,
the carto and the deck.
You Montas of the city,
the Cardo,
uh,
being the north South Main Street and the deck,
the monitor being the east West Street,
and then intersecting very close to the center of the city.
And it's usually very close to that same center that you find the forum or great
open a space meeting and marketplace of the city as well as a host of other
buildings,
basilica market and so on.
And then on the highest hill of the town of poser,
a capitalism,
a temple to Jupiter,
Juno and Minerva on that highest spot,
the most important religious,
uh,
structure of that town.
That's the town of Kosha.
Uh,
and then the other more important one is the town of Austria,
the port of Rome.
Uh,
the town of Ostia,
which was first founded that in 350 BC.
And it was at that time that a military camp or cast from was a c a s t r u m a
cast from was laid out,
uh,
there,
and you could see a plan of that Castro,
you the dark dotted line two years,
the original plan of Ostia three 50 BC,
all the rest that you see around it as a city,
as it grew into the second century,
a d when it had its epilogue.
Bresson's.
So we see the original city here and you can see it is perfectly regular.
And I mentioned to you last time that this is very different from what happened
in Rome.
Rome,
uh,
grew in a very haphazard way over the centuries.
There was never any real attempt to plan the city.
Uh,
but when Romans,
the Romans were left to build the kind of ideal city,
the city that they thought was the ideal Roman city,
they almost always built it in a very regular fashion as a square or as a
rectangle,
as regular as they could make it an ad varied depending upon the terrain.
There was a lot of hills.
And so on,
it might end up with a somewhat more regular shape,
but here you see it at its most regular planned like a costume or a military
camp,
uh,
rectangular with the two main streets,
the Cardo north South Street,
the deck,
you Montas the east West Street crossing exactly at the center of the city.
And then what's located there,
the form of the city,
the great open meeting and marketplace,
and then all the other,
uh,
major buildings deployed around that.
Uh,
and then of course the residential structures on the shops interspersed among
those in this typical Roman town plan of the fourth century BC.
I want to spend the rest of today's lecture on the three most important
buildings in a sense that I'm going to show you today.
Uh,
visa vi,
the development of Roman religious architecture,
specifically temple architecture.
And I think I'm going to actually call for your help.
You've learned a lot already and I think you now know enough to help me along a
little bit here on sorting out some of these temples.
One of them is located in Rome and the other two are located outside of Rome.
I'll show you the map again in the center and the second so that you can see
where those other two are.
But I'm going to begin with the one in Rome,
which takes me back to Google earth here.
Uh,
to show you the situation of the so called Temple of poor Tunis in Rome.
That dates to we believe sometime it was put up sometime between one 20 and 80
BC in Rome.
A,
you're going to get so good at this that you're going to be able to point all
these places out without me.
Uh,
but uh,
we're looking back again over,
this is a Palatine Hill.
We're looking at a slightly different angle.
Palatine hill over here,
the very edge of the coliseum.
You can see in the upper left,
the great to be a day 40 and periodically and miscellany over here,
the imperial fora here,
the wedding cake,
a victor manual,
if Victoriano that I showed you last time over here,
the more modern building the capital line hill,
you can see the Oval Piatsa of Michelangelo right here.
And uh,
what the,
and the circus maximus over here.
And uh,
for any of you have been to Rome,
the Easel Lottie Barina,
that wonderful little island,
that one can cross the bridge to get to in Rome down here.
So here's the Tiber river looking nasty as it usually does.
It's very,
um,
green and uh,
not,
not the sort of place you'd want to take a swim in.
As you can,
well imagine a,
but you see the Tiber river here.
Uh,
and if you look very closely,
you will see two temples.
This is a round temple,
which has the very uninvented is called today,
very uninvented Lee,
the round temple by the Tiber,
uh,
the round temple by the Tiber for obvious reasons.
And then hear a rectangular temple that looks like it has a red roof because it
was undergoing things.
It's been undergoing reconstruction and restoration recently.
Uh,
you see that here?
This is the temple of Fortuna,
so you can see in conjunction to another temple,
it was built very close to the river,
to the Tiber river.
Now let's look at the plan together of the temple up Pour Tunis.
Based on your understanding now of typical,
uh,
trust skin,
religious architecture,
typical Greek religious architecture,
what would you say about this plant?
Is this more like an a trust skin temple or more like a Greek temple?
I can't remember if,
I think,
I forgot to mention with regard to the Parthenon that not only does the,
the typical Greek temple,
the fifth century BC have a staircase that encircles the entire monument.
It has a colonnade,
a freestanding colonnade that in circles the entire monument.
And that's called a peripheral p.
E r I t t e R,
a,
l,
a peripheral colonnade.
So based on what you know about,
uh,
the temple of Jupiter,
Omc and the temple of,
and the Parthenon in Athens,
does this plan in plan,
when we look at this building,
does this look more like an a trust skin plan or like a Rick plan?
Okay.
Mr Roma.
Good.
All right.
Okay.
Yeah,
it's,
it looks like it might be a combination.
Give me what the trust can characteristics are first
chorus and also the,
this,
the,
the single staircase.
Absolutely.
Which gives it a facade orientation.
Is there a triple entrance way?
I mean,
there are there spaces between the columns.
These are columns here,
but look at the seller.
The cell is a single seller,
so this is not a capitalism,
but there are spaces.
You're right between the columns.
So take us a little further with the columns.
You can see the columns in a deep porch.
The porch,
freestanding columns in the front are freestanding.
So facade orientation,
single staircase,
deep porch,
freestanding columns in the porch,
in this case,
a single seller.
Those are all a trust skin characteristics.
So it looks as if we are dealing here essentially within a trust can plan,
but you are right.
What's your name?
Neil.
Neil was right.
However that this is a combination in that there are columns that go around the
monument,
but is it a peripheral colonnade?
Neal?
Probably not.
Why not?
Because what's different about these columns?
You can see it in plan there.
They go all the way around,
but they're not freestanding.
They're attached or engaged into the wall.
They're attached to the wall.
What do we call that?
We call that a pseudo for rip curl pollinate.
So yeah,
it kind of looks like it goes around but it doesn't really because it's attached
to the wall and it kind of gives that sense of flatness that we got in the trust
can temple.
So you're,
you were absolutely on the mark.
It's a combination of the two and that is exactly what we see coming together at
this particular time in Roman temple architecture,
this wonderful way in which the Romans have looked at a trust skin precedents.
They've looked at Greek presidents,
they what they like.
They mix it up,
as I said before,
in a way in which best represents their own culture,
their own religion,
uh,
and create something that we're going to see becomes distinctively Roman.
The building is very well preserved.
So we can go on to actually look at it.
Here it is,
uh,
stands in almost pristine shape in Rome today,
right near the Tiber river.
As I mentioned,
uh,
a wonderful temple,
in which we see some of those features that Neil has already pointed to.
And that is the facade orientation,
the single staircase,
the deep porch,
the freestanding columns in that porch from a distance.
It does indeed look peripheral.
It looks like their columns all the way around.
But as you look closely,
you will see that the columns are indeed attached to the wall on the side and
around the other side.
Now,
now that you see the actual view,
there are some other things that give this away as a temple that is clearly also
built,
been built under very strong Greek influence.
And what are those
stone?
Yes,
absolutely.
This is not made.
This is,
this is not a wooden mud brick terracotta temple.
This is a temple that is made out of stone.
It's not made out of marble.
It's made out of,
uh,
of,
um,
travertine.
It has travertine,
A travertine is an Italian stone bought from,
brought from or quarried at the,
uh,
the town of Tivoli Tib,
O,
l,
I,
which we'll talk about a lot in the course of the semester.
A travertine brought Tivoli is about an hour's highspeed drive today from Rome,
obviously longer in antiquity,
but it's fairly proximate to Rome.
So this wonderful stone travertine from Tim Tivoli brought to serve as a facing
for the podium,
uh,
and for the columns and the columns.
So it is,
it is essentially a stone structure.
We'll see that the walls are made of Tufa.
Uh,
but those walls were stuccoed over with white stucco.
So that the impression that you would have gotten if you were,
if you,
in ancient times when this was in more pristine condition,
was that you were looking at a white marble temple,
which would've certainly conjured up the idea that you were looking at a temple
that was made a log wreck that was made in the Greek style.
Anything else that gives away the influence of Greek?
Arkady?
Any of you know your orders,
Neil ionic order.
Good.
And I see Ionic,
the three major,
and you'll find this in your terms and concepts.
So bone up on those there.
Uh,
the Doric,
the ionic and the Corinthian.
We'll look at all of them today.
The ionic order.
What characterizes the ionic order are these what are called spiral volumes?
Vol.
U T e s spiraled volumes.
And you can see those here.
This is a typical ionic column clearly made.
We don't see the Etruscans using this,
uh,
clearly made under the influence,
the very strong influence of Greek architecture,
Greek temple architecture.
Here's a view of the temple of cartoonists from the side and from the rear.
We once again see the way those columns and circle the structure but are engaged
into the wall.
Uh,
you can also see the blocks of Tufa Stone Ashler blocks just as we saw them in
the walls of two histone use tier.
And you can get some sense of some remains of some of the stucco that was
stuccoed over in white.
So that from a distance at least you would have the impression that the whole
building was made out of stone and even stone.
You might even be fooled into thinking it wasn't travertine,
it was marble.
Uh,
if you were far enough away.
I also need to mention something very important for the future of Roman
architecture.
And that is that concrete construction was used in the podium.
You don't see it.
It was only used inside the podium.
The reason it was used inside the podium is concrete is very strong.
It can sustain great weight.
And the Romans recognized very early on that they could use it and utilitarian
ways,
uh,
to help support buildings.
At this particular time,
the concrete,
um,
was,
uh,
you know,
was made up of rubble and liquid mortar and a kind of dash of volcanic dust.
And they brought all of that together,
uh,
to create a material that could sustain a great wait.
So they use it here for utilitarian purposes where,
but we're going to see already next Tuesday,
uh,
the Romans beginning to take advantage of concrete for,
for a very expressive purposes and,
and how well they do it,
which culminates ultimately obviously in buildings like the Pantheon and it's
incredible don't,
here's the detail of the ionic capitals of the,
uh,
temple,
a port Tunis.
You can also see this building has as it would have if it were made in Greece,
what's called an ionic frieze and Ionic frieze,
which if you look very carefully,
there's some remains of the candelabra and the garlands that hung from those
candelabra,
uh,
in the original design of this temple.
I also think it's interesting to look,
here's a view again of the Temple of Port Tunis as it looks today.
This is a 19th century painting of the Temple of Port Tunis.
As it looked at the time it was done by that artist.
And what you see is something that I have already alluded to,
but which is extremely important for,
uh,
the preservation of buildings like this.
And that is that this building,
the temple of port tune is like so many in Rome was reused in later times and
transformed into something else.
And it is probably only because it was transformed into something else that
it's,
that it survived as well as it did because you can see that what happened is
that they walled in the front.
Uh,
they gave it a fee,
a real facade,
uh,
a doorway,
three windows,
uh,
a medallion with the Madonna across at the top of Bell Tower.
And they turned it into a church and they turned it into a church.
And it,
because it was an active church,
uh,
it was kept in good shape.
You can see those ionic capitals and the freeze with the garlands and so on of
the Temple of Port Tunis.
And you can also see the round temple,
by the way,
which still does Sam stand also over here.
Uh,
right near it,
near the Tiber river.
Uh,
so this is the reason that we were,
we are fortunate that the Temple of port tune is survives and it does survive in
large part because again,
it was transformed into a church in later times.
And this is one of the fascinations of Rome,
by the way.
You never know.
I mean,
so many churches mask earlier buildings.
There's one right near not too far from these,
uh,
where you can actually see three Roman temples that stood side by sides.
His son were,
were incorporated into the churches,
saw Nick Nicola Karcher a,
uh,
and you can actually see the remains of all three of those temples,
used in PR in that church.
And it's one of the fascinations obviously,
of wandering around the city of Rome.
The other two,
the other two,
uh,
temples that I want to show you today.
We're looking back at the map of this particular area are located at Corey.
And you can see the proximity of Corey,
not just to Rome,
but also to Ostia right here,
the city of Corey and the city of Tivoli.
And now you see Tivoli from we're travertine comes the location of Tivoli in
relationship again to Rome.
It's not very far,
which is why the building material was so easily transportable from Tivoli to
Rome.
Let's look first at Cory.
Cory is one of those incredible you,
those of you have traveled around Italy,
you know,
outside of roam around Italy.
No,
that one of the glories of traveling in Italy is to go into some of these
medieval hilltowns.
You go into these places and you,
you,
whether by car or by bus or cab,
you make your way up to the very peak of that hill town.
It's very picturesque.
And then ultimately you get to the top and you stand up there and you get this
incredible panorama over the city and over the landscape.
Uh,
that's the kind of place Corey is.
It's a medieval Hilltown.
Uh,
but leave it to the Romans.
And they had a knack for doing this wherever they went.
They found the best location in Corey,
uh,
for their temple.
And this temple is located almost at the very peak of the hill of Corey.
Uh,
and usually you have to drive all the way up to see the temple.
The so called Temple of Hercules at Cory.
We don't really know if this was put up to Hercules,
but it's been called the temple of Hercules for a long time.
So we continue to call it that.
Uh,
and you see it here in plan,
in restored view with its little complex in front,
uh,
and then the temple as it looks today.
So looking at this one then we can see again that we are dealing with an a trust
can plan a with freestanding columns in the porch.
You can't see it here,
but you can up there.
It does have a single staircase.
It's a kind of pyramidal staircase.
It has a side as well as a front or sides as well as friends.
But you can see it does not go all the way around as a Greek,
uh,
as a Greek,
um,
staircase would've,
it's focused on the front.
So we once again have this idea of single staircase on the front facade
orientation of the temple,
deep porch,
freestanding columns in that porch,
single seller.
In this case.
Now,
Neil,
what happens when you go around and this one?
Yup.
Well it's good.
I mean there's no columns around.
There are no columns are no columns.
It's not a peripheral colonnade.
It's not an,
it's not a suit all crypto cause it doesn't have coffee.
But what is this?
And they look sort of like flat columns.
There are what are called Pilasters,
p I,
P I l a s t e r s pilasters which are essentially flat columns also.
It does have some articulation.
You can see them up there is,
there is articulation but it's been flattened out still further.
So once again in the trust can plan with some nod to Greece in the sense that
there's a recognition we've got have something that goes around here but they
don't want to take it out.
They don't want to use an actual column and they flatten it out.
Uh,
as you can see,
so well here.
Now again,
anyone who knows your orders,
what order is,
what Greek order is used here in this building.
Yep.
The doric,
the doric order,
the most,
the simplest and most severe order is used here,
the Greek doric order and the system of Greek.
Try glyphs and met,
appease,
try glyphs and metaphase.
I'll show you a detail in a moment and I'll explain what those are.
So the Greek doric order try glyphs and Mehta piece,
uh,
for this temple.
And one thing we couldn't see and that plan a is the high podium.
So that's another,
a trust skin feature.
So once again,
we see this very interesting and very eclectic,
bringing together all the trust and elements and Greek elements in early in what
we can call early Roman temple architecture.
Here's another detail of the temple at Cory.
Uh,
you can get a size.
This was like,
I took this on a very gray day,
so you don't get the sense of the glory of what it can look like up there.
Uh,
but you get some sense of its situation right at the edge,
uh,
with a,
with a spectacular,
on a beautiful day,
spectacular panorama of the mountains,
the other mountains in this area and of the Hilltown itself.
And here we can see the doric order better,
very simple with the soap called try glyphs and met a t,
R I,
G,
l,
Y p.
H.
E n n e t.
O.
P.
E.
S.
Try glyphs and Mehta piece.
Tried lifts are triple strided bands.
Uh,
and you can see them up there,
the triples,
right and bands and inbetween them square panels.
So this alteration of triple strided,
Brooke,
blah bands,
the tribe glyphs and the square panels,
the metal piece,
which is,
uh,
which is typical of the doric order,
the Greek doric order.
You see it in the Parthenon,
for example,
and it has been,
uh,
taken over here by the Romans.
You also see something very interesting about Roman building practice here
because if you look at the columns,
you'll see that the upper part of the columns are what is called fluted,
fluted.
They have striations in them,
uh,
and uh,
but they're not fluted at the bottom.
You can see it stops right here.
The fluting stops here and the bottom is playing.
What's the reason for that?
Well,
we know that even in Greek Hellenistic Times that tech tech,
not that that approach was taken,
uh,
and we believe it was done for two reasons.
One practical purposes.
Uh,
why are they not there?
No flutes at the bottom because people are more likely to lean up against the
columns at the bottom than they are obviously at the top.
And when people lean up against columns,
the flutes start to break off.
Uh,
so they decided not to flute the bottom,
but it may have been also for decorative reasons because we'll see when we get
to palm pay in the very near future that there are many columns at Pompei that
have a floating at the top painted white.
And then the bottom,
the plane bottom painted red,
uh,
for reasons of taste and decoration.
And it's very possible we do know that ancient,
I don't want to destroy any illusions here,
but ms to ancient buildings were very often painted and ancient sculpture was
always painted.
Uh,
so these might have been a lot more garish looking in ancient times than they
are today,
which might also have taken away from this sense of having a marble building.
So that's something that we probably should keep in mind as we evaluate these
structures.
The last one I want to show you today is the temple of Vesta at Tivoli.
Also beautifully situated.
It's a temple.
The dates to ADBC also,
probably not a temple of Vesta,
but it's around temple and Temple's of Vesta.
We're up and round,
so it's tended to be called by scholars,
the temple of Vesta,
uh,
in ADBC.
Again,
beautifully situated out over a,
a,
a particularly verdant,
uh,
area of Tivoli where you can look down and around this beautiful area,
this of waterfall,
very nearby.
It's just magnificent.
And you can see it's not surprising that some enterprising family decided to
build the Sybilla a restaurant,
uh,
right here.
Uh,
and there's,
uh,
there's a patio on which one can go and eat under umbrellas and so on and so
forth.
Uh,
here,
here's the temple,
the ancient temple of ADBC.
And once again,
we look at a plan over here.
Uh,
and I also show you a view of the so called Temple of Venus from Hadrian's villa
activity.
Just to make the point that,
um,
this is,
this is as Greek as we've gotten thus far in the sense that the Greeks really
loved round temples.
They built them a lot.
There was a very famous temple of Venus and their case Aphrodite on the island
of Kauai,
Dos,
uh,
and that temple of Venus on the island of tonight oss is the one that was
duplicated by Hadrian for his villain.
We'll talk about this later in the semester,
but I showed the one at Hadrian's villa because it gives you a very good sense
of what this structure was like in ancient Greek times as well.
Because we think it's a replica around structure,
freestanding columns in circling the entire building,
low podium,
a staircase around that podium that encircled the entire building and then a
temple of Venus in the center.
Uh,
when we look at the plan of this structure,
we will see it's pretty close.
It's round,
it's got temples that are free.
It has columns that are freestanding that and circle the entire structure,
but it has a higher,
as we're going to see.
And even though it's circular,
they'd given it a staircase on one side a which gives it even,
even even around temple,
which you think of something you'd just keep circling.
Circling has a kind of facade orientation in this instance.
So they are,
so they are applying some of these Etruscan skin characteristics to a,
an almost pure,
uh,
Greek type.
Here's a view.
It's very well preserved,
a view of the temple of Vesta actively as it looks today.
Uh,
and what order is this?
The Corinthian order,
the Corinthian,
the last of the three great Greek orders,
the Corinthian order,
which is very ornate,
which I'll describe in a moment.
We see it here supporting a freeze.
Once again in this case of freeze with garlands and libation dishes.
Uh,
we can see here also,
it is a very tall podium.
So an imposition of an Etruscan element on this structure.
Uh,
Greek orders,
uh,
the,
the building is made out of stone,
the columns and the base,
the columns and the facing of the base are made out of stone.
In this case,
a travertine,
once again,
travertine again was quarried right next door.
I mean,
this is Tivoli right there.
Uh,
and you can see the travertine detailing on the doorway and on the windows as
well.
Uh,
but what you see here that we haven't seen before,
remember I talked about the use of,
of concrete in the podium of the temple pour Tunis in Rome.
Here we see concrete use for the wall of the Sella.
If the Greeks had put up this building,
they would have made the walls of the cella out of stone and they would have cut
those stones very carefully to create the kind of curvature that was needed.
But the Romans were getting really smart in terms of making things easier for
themselves.
They realize it was going to be a lot easier to build a round structure with
concrete than it was to have to carve all those stones and just those and just
those shapes.
So they have used concrete here for the seller.
We still could argue this is utilitarian purpose,
but at the same time,
I think it's beginning to demonstrate straight to us the expressive
possibilities of concrete.
Uh,
and we also see if you look very carefully,
uh,
the way in which we'll talk much more about this next week,
but concrete,
uh,
in order to make concrete,
impermeable to water and so on and so forth,
you have to face it with something.
And they faced it with very small stones of irregular shape,
which we call uncertain work or opus and carried on.
But we can copy us new word,
Inc e r t u m opus,
and carried them,
which is put into the concrete wall.
It is still wet to give it,
to give it the ability to withstand water,
but also to give it an attractive,
a stone like appearance.
And you can see that opus and Keratin work used here.
Here's a detail of the wall where you can see its curvature and also see,
uh,
that opus and character work.
And here is a detail of the capital's,
the Corinthian capitals that are used here.
What's characteristic of Corinthian capitals is that they have like,
like uh,
the eye on it.
I'd like the Ionic,
they have volume to the spiral volumes,
but they are much more,
they are much smaller and much more delicate and they are in a sense
incorporated into the flowering plant.
This is called an a canvas plant,
a c,
a n t h u s a canvas plants grow all over Italy.
You see them everywhere.
Uh,
so they are just image.
They're just copying a plant that is indigenous to Italy.
They use those,
a campus leaves that seem to grow out of the column to incorporate the spirals
and there's always a,
uh,
a prominent central flower that is also part of this motif.
It's important to note at the beginning that while the Greeks use the doric and
the ionic order almost exclusively,
the Greeks did invent the Corinthian order.
They used it in very late Hellenistic tums,
but quite infrequently the Romans used all three.
But we are going to see very quickly that they decide pretty early on that they
eye on that the Corinthian capital is their capital and almost every building
we'll see some exceptions,
but almost every building we'll see in the course of the semester uses the
Corinthian capital.
Why did they take to the Corinthian capital in particular?
Uh,
this is something we can think about in the courses a semester and debate.
I think it has to do probably with two major reasons.
One,
it was particularly decorative,
very highly decorative,
more so than the others,
but maybe even more important than that is the fact that the Corinthian capital,
at least in my opinion,
looks the best from the most vantage points because it's pretty much the same
all the way around.
Uh,
the,
the Doric is pretty severe.
The ionic looks best from certain angles where you can really see the volume as
well,
less wealth from other angles.
But this looks pretty much the same wherever you see it.
So it's a very flexible,
uh,
and,
and easily easy to use a capital type.
We see also here,
I've referred to this last time,
but I want to describe it for you just in the second we see here,
the um,
the uh,
core offering,
I,N ,
g,
the offering of the ceiling,
which is basically placing,
placing a series of receiving a square elements there to give the sense of depth
or in the,
uh,
in the ceiling.
And then in the center you see these flowers that match up nicely with those in
the Corinthian capitals,
which are called Rosettes,
and we'll see core offering and the use of rosettes quite extensively in Roman
architecture.
I mentioned the restaurant,
uh,
the Sabella used to be a horrendous restaurant.
I,
I was,
when I started taking pictures of Roman buildings,
I guess there's a little more timid than I am today.
So I always thought,
well,
Gee,
if I'm going to go into the terrorist and want to take the picture of the
temple,
I'm kind of going to have to eat there.
I would never do that now,
but I did that at one point.
I made the mistake of eating in this restaurant twice and I never went back
again.
Uh,
but when I went just a couple of years ago to see the temple,
once again,
I saw that they had really,
some new owners must have come along.
They've really expanded.
The restaurant looks very pretty now.
Uh,
and this is the terrorism,
which one can eat?
I haven't tried it,
but I might actually next time I go,
I want to just end with a couple of remarks.
One is that one of the interesting things is that all,
although the sto,
the temples that we talked about today were in part made out of stone in all
cases travertine.
We do know that already in the year 146 BC,
so earlier than a couple of the temples we looked at just now and one 46 BC,
they had the Romans had already ready put up a temple,
another temple to Jupiter near the Tiber river that was made entirely of marble
entirely of marble.
So they were already beginning to think not just of their own local stone or
stones that were from local play close places in Italy,
but,
but imported marble.
Uh,
and uh,
so I want to you to know that so that we can talk about it in the future.
And we also know that in one 42,
the ceiling of the temple of Jupiter Omc was gilded.
And we also know that not long after that they repaved the temple of Jupiter Omc
and gave it a multicolored stone.
So what this is telling us is that a lot of people in Rome,
we're beginning to think of,
of temples that were more ornate than anything had become,
had come before anything that had come before.
There are some very conservative individuals who did some writing at this
particular time who bemoan the fact that they had,
that the Romans had moved away from the trust in temples made out of wood and
mud brick and so on and were becoming too ostentatious in their taste.
But I think these new Greek style temples,
we're definitely here to stay.
And I just wanted to end up with a quote from Cicero,
uh,
after one of these fires,
these fires that so often raged in Rome,
the great fire of 83 BC,
uh,
Cicero,
talks about the,
the rebuilding still again at the temple of Jupiter Omc.
And I quote from Cicero when he says,
let us feel,
let us feel that conflagration to have been the will of heaven and it's purpose
not to destroy the Temple of Almighty Jupiter,
but to demand of us.
One more splendid and magnificent.
What did that mean?
More Greek,
more Greek looking,
more marble.
And last comment I'm going to make is to make the temple of Jupiter Omc even
more magnificent.
The Roman general seller who was sacking Athens at this particular time,
goes into Athens.
And after he sacks,
it takes it over,
conquers it.
He goes up to the biggest temple in town,
the temple of Olympian Zeus,
Zeus,
the Greek counterpart of Jupiter.
And he takes some of the Collins,
actually steals some of the columns from that temple,
has them shipped back to Rome and he incorporates them into the temple of
Jupiter.
Omc on the capital line hill,
these columns,
my last point,
these columns were 55 and one half feet tall.
Uh,
so that,
and they were made of solid marble.
So that gives you some sense of the objectives of the Romans visa be temple
building,
uh,
in the first century BC.